it's time for the lawn gene conosco a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the lawn gene but nor
wats company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lon gene good evening this is
David Ross may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the lawn
gene Cronus Co from the CBS television
news staff Larry lesser and Winston
Burdette our distinguished guest for
this evening is dr. Gabriel hoagie
economic advisor to the president it
goes without saying that it's difficult
to get an appointment with the president
of the United States but few persons see
President Eisenhower more often than our
guest tonight he has a set date at the
white house at eleven o'clock every
Monday morning he goes there and keeps
the president informed of the economic
pulse rate of the nation now dr. Haga
the president has reported that the
recession of or the business downturn of
last year and the early part of this
year is over and that he predicts that
the next month's will see a business
upturn could you tell us on what he
bases his calculations yes miss Lasser
yesterday the president put out a
statement as you know in which he said
that in his opinion the the slump the
recession the adjustment whatever you
want to call it that's been going on
since about the middle of last year had
come to a halt I think his confidence is
based on things like this hard facts the
level of construction and the
prospective level of construction the
very satisfactory performance of retail
sales the business expenditures on plant
and equipment which create jobs and
create demand for
goods and for the metal industries the
strength of the financial markets the
fact that inventories which have been
very heavy and have had to be adjusted
downward over these months are now
getting into better shape with respect
to sales I think things like that hard
facts in the business situation have
given him reason for cautious optimism
well dr. Hagee isn't it true though that
the unemployment situation is worse Nell
and it has been for several years is
this is there any assurance of these
photos going to get their jobs back well
this matter of unemployment the
president also considered yesterday in
his statement mr. the sewer he pointed
out that unemployment now at something
over 3 million is up from what it was a
year ago it is however lower than it was
in 1949 and nineteen hundred and fifty
and also he pointed out that the
increase in unemployment has been
brought to a stop and that employment
has been rising steadily and out of
these facts he thinks that when fall
comes we'll begin to get a good attack
on that unemployment figure well dr.
Haga does this administration think that
the present level of unemployment is
necessary to the economic health of the
nation indeed not mr. Burdett the
present level of unemployment which
though it is moderate in comparison with
previous levels of unemployment is more
than the economy needs or can usefully
have with respect to a good level of
employment i would think that it's at
least a million higher than any normal
kind of unemployment or whatever you
want to call it doctor how is it
possible to avoid political bias when
making reports to the president is it
possible to paint an economy of a
political administration in anything but
the most roseate colors well the people
who have the responsibility of telling
the president what the true picture is
certainly have to be on guard any doctor
who deliberately miss reads the
thermometer or the electrocardiograph is
not going to be very much help to the
people he's working for
the facts are presented to the president
the advice that comes to him from
political advisors whether he among his
congressional associates or his cabinet
associates in connection with the
evaluation of the total economic picture
is of course something that then must be
made but the President himself is a hard
shooter for facts and that's the way
that he puts them out to the people you
must say so if I mean Winston would you
say that it would be very difficult for
the president to make a prediction that
things were going to very bad they were
going to get worse wouldn't he have to
put it in the best possible light
political light well I think President
Eisenhower in any particular situation
such as this would reduce the facts like
he did yesterday in his report to the
people and these are reports from
government sources are available to
everybody and I think that yesterday in
his statement he used these facts and
indicated that in his opinion these
facts meant certain things about the
economy and as far as I can tell from
the reaction people generally have
agreed with it sir how great a personal
interest does the president events and
economic problems well I'm glad to
respond to that question mr. Burdett I
recall in 1952 people used to say about
the president that well here's a
military man what does he really know
about the problems of the country I
first met the president to be in the
summer of nineteen hundred and fifty two
and in the conversations we had about
economic matters I was immediately
impressed with how much he knew about
foreign economic affairs about the
economies of other countries and also
hear how much he knew about industrial
mobilization problems in connection with
war today I would be willing to assert
flatly that there are a few people with
whom you or I could sit down who could
go as deeply and wisely into the
problems of agriculture into the
problems of resource use into the
problems of many aspects of our economy
than the president I think it's
extraordinary how he has mastered the
this tremendous range of problems and
brought to bear in his own judgment and
now a wide range of it well you were
talking about in technical terms of for
dr. Hal gay about inventory recessions
and we've in the past heard of
overproduction and under consumption but
how much does psychology actually play
in the economy of the country and is it
possible to control the psychology of
the buyer or the producer I think
psychology is a very important to matter
after all in our kind of an economy the
decisions to buy are made by millions of
individuals and by millions of farmers
by millions of businessmen who produce
things whether or not they elect to
spend their money or go into debt to buy
something is dependent upon their
judgment of what the future is going to
be like and they sell what they make can
they liquidate their debts psychology is
tremendously important and therefore the
period that we went through I think in
the first half of this year when they
were tremendous fears in certain areas
that we were going to grind our way down
into a depression that frightened
certain people I think now however that
with more and more people are emerging
from their economic storm cellars they
believe the president when he says that
the road ahead looks like it can be a
good road for us if we do the right
things dr. hakkie which is more
important the psychology of the
businessman who might order things from
a factory or the psychology of a
consumer who might or might not want to
buy well the consumer of course in the
aggregate is a bigger spender than a
businessman in terms of purchases of
plant and equipment several times over
and therefore in the aggregate if
consumers went on strike or if consumers
indulged into buying orgy such as they
did after Korea broke in 1950 you get
profound effects but it is necessary in
our kind of an economy I think mr.
LeSueur for that section of our total
spending the section that we identify as
business spending on plant and equipment
which runs now around 20
28 billion dollars a year which is
perhaps small compared to consumer
spending of upwards of 10 times that
much but it is very important for the
demand for the heavy goods industries
and for the workers who work in those
industries that the psychology of the
people who have to commit funds who have
to spend on those things he's a
confident one and is a buoyant one well
speaking of the heavy goods industry how
much of a role does defense play in the
economy of the country in the business
cycle well defense of course in the last
several years has been a big taker of
Labor and of materials in this economy
in the past year this has been declining
and certainly that was one of the items
which had to be taken into account in
the adjustment that we have been having
we are undoubtedly going to go ahead and
have reasonably high levels of defense
expenditure compared to anything we knew
before World War two and it's going to
play a role but I think it's going to be
a much more steady role unless of course
the Russians make a mistake and pushes
into war what do you foresee for the
rest of this year a slow climb or a
sudden surge I would expect mr. Burdett
that with the resumption of activity in
the fall according to a typical seasonal
pattern that's existed for many many
years we ought to see a steady
resumption of activity reemployment
increasing production of a more stable
kind perhaps than has typically marked
the surges of activity up and down in
the history of this country in the last
20 years dr. huggy face it everyone
every economist was very optimistic in
1929 and recently they have made
predictions which have fallen wide of
the mark some said they were going to be
recession some said there didn't how can
we actually be sure that in looking
ahead to the future that we aren't
completely wide of the mark and there
may be a tremendous boom or tremendous
bust well you know somebody said once
that if you lay all the economist's end
to end they wouldn't reach a conclusion
and I think that perhaps you will find
economists are having different views
about the future I think the majority of
people who follow this closely today
however have gotten over the depression
six months ago and now the debate rather
is the rate at which we're going to grow
over the next period ahead well how much
of a role dr. Haga is the federal
government actually played can you
create a inflation or a deflation or
that up to the businessman on a consumer
the federal government of course if it
wants to pursue radically altered
policies such as trying to for example
unbalanced its budget very rapidly by
billions of dollars of spending in
various ways and by pursuing and
exceedingly unwise monetary policy I
think could could make an inflation
rather quickly and similarly if it
wanted to pursue monetary policies and
budgetary policies have a radically
constricted the restrictive type could
have a profound effect but I think by
and large the economy of America is
increasingly going to be dominated and
directed by the millions of Americans
all throughout this land who are
confident about the future and whose
decisions are going to aggregate into a
growing reasonably stable economy and if
the if the if the government can pursue
right policies in that area I think
we're going to have a fine period of it
thank you very much dr. huggies been
very interesting to have you here
tonight the opinions expressed on the
launching Kronus cope with those of the
speakers the editorial board for this
edition of the law and gene Cronus cope
was Larry lesser and Winston Burdette
our distinguished guest was dr. Gabriel
Hoggy economic adviser to the president